For every gripping, well-crafted piece of
cinema released in a given year, it seems
there must be at least one misguided, no-good
slog of a film released to match it.
2019 is no exception and these are some of
the worst movies of the bunch.
Overcomer is the latest effort from brothers
Alex and Stephen Kendrick, purveyors of faith-based
flicks such as Fireproof, Courageous, and
War Room.
While religious dramas haven't exactly earned
a reputation for being critical darlings,
Overcomer still managed to fall well below
expectations, owing to everything from its
clunky title to its stilted performances to
its relentless proselytizing.
Mark Dujsik of RogerEbert.com channeled the
site's namesake in dismantling the movie for
its steadfast refusal to be well, to be an
actual movie.
He wrote:
"There's about half a movie in Overcomer.
The other half or so is a pretty half-hearted
sermon.
Neither half is particularly worthwhile, and
the whole is cheap, cheesy, and, to put it
charitably, churchy."
Variety's Nick Schager concurred, opining:
"[Overcomer is] a drama that affects sensitivity
while nonetheless operating as a blunt instrument.
Its one-note sermonizing should help it appeal
to its target audience, but those not already
in the fold will likely be left unmoved."
It's an aesthetic that has come to be expected
from faith-based films, but the biggest critical
burn was levied by Movie Nation's Roger Moore,
who was most offended by the Kendrick brothers'
failure to respect their craft.
He wrote:
"There's just nothing here...
Even as comfort food for true believers, Overcomer
cannot overcome its myriad shortcomings."
Angel Has Fallen is the third in a series
of films following the exploits of Secret
Service agent Mike Banning, preceded by 2013's
Olympus Has Fallen and 2016's London Has Fallen.
How a third installment was warranted is anybody's
guess, since neither film scored with critics
or cleaned up at the box office.
The series as a whole just seems to exist
at this point to serve as a way to poke fun
at Gerard Butler.
"It’s funny ha?
It’s funny I know I get it."
Angel continued the films' tradition of lazily
plotted, half-heartedly shot action and intrigue
and its paint-by-numbers aesthetic was judged
by the vast majority of critics to be an insult
to any action fans who require at least a
modicum of personal investment from filmmakers.
Flat characters and nonsensical plotting can
often be forgiven if the action component
delivers, but director Ric Roman Waugh's uninspired
staging and photography was the final nail
in the coffin.
But if one thing can be said for Angel Has
Fallen, the movie at least brought out some
decent snark in virtually every critic who
saw it including FilmWeek's Claudia Pugh,
who wrote:
"The franchise has fallen, and it can't get
up."
Another year, another mess of a movie starring
John Travolta, who at this point seems so
unbelievably far from his Pulp Fiction glory
days that many fans are probably beginning
to wonder if he ever actually was in that
movie.
The Fanatic stars Travolta in an autistic
man who goes completely off the rails after
being rebuffed by his favorite actor.
But is this story handled with any sensitivity
or nuance?
Well, for readers who were fans of popular
music in the late '90s and early '00s, the
fact that this film was co-written and directed
by Limp Bizkit's Fred Durst should tell you
everything you need to know about its sensibilities.
Robert Abele of The Wrap penned a particularly
brutal takedown of the film, seeming to take
its very existence as a personal affront.
He wrote:
"[The Fanatic] is a brainless, exploitative
folly which gives John Travolta free rein
to mine the history of cringe-worthy autism
portrayals for an offensively garish Frankenstein
pantomime of unhinged obsession."
John J. Rambo might have been responsible
for roughly as many box office dollars as
he was dead bad guys, but nobody has ever
really seen his movies as anything other than
mindless, disposable action flicks… with
the sole exception of First Blood.
The Rambo series has also been increasingly
burdened by troublesome political overtones
over the years, and with Rambo: Last Blood,
the series hit its nadir prompting the vast
majority of the critics who viewed it to savage
it in their reviews.
Critics found the film's depiction of Mexico
to be particularly ill-advised and that's
putting it kindly.
Salon's Matthew Rozsa wrote:
"[The movie] is less an escapist action movie
and more a dramatized manifestation of the
most notorious sentences from Donald Trump's
presidential campaign announcement speech...
When you take action film genre tropes and
graft a political narrative onto them, people
often imbibe the ideology along with the spectacle.
That is when they become propaganda."
Rozsa's assessment wasn't even the most blunt
or the most damning Matthew Turner of The
List wrote:
"The horrific finale makes Rambo himself seem
like the real monster, making you briefly
wonder if Stallone is aware of the irony.
On balance, one suspects not."
It's never going to be easy adapting an acclaimed,
Pulitzer Prize-winning novel for the screen,
but Donna Tartt's The Goldfinch was always
going to be trickier than most owing to its
hugely complex, thematically-dense narrative.
Unfortunately, the material proved to be too
heavy for director John Crowley and screenwriter
Peter Straughan, who squandered the talents
of a heavyweight cast in service of a flat
and inexcusably boring adaptation.
It wasn't that the filmmakers didn't follow
the blueprint laid out in the novel; it was
just the lack of skill and finesse with which
they did so.
The Atlantic's David Sims summed up the general
consensus nicely, writing:
"Watching The Goldfinch is like having the
plot of a novel read to you not the novel
itself, but merely its long and winding synopsis,
a bitesize summary that still manages to feel
endless."
Most reviewers agreed that the flick's meandering
pace, dearth of emotion, and assembly line
feel made it a challenging watch in all the
wrong ways but perhaps the most painful zinger
was lobbed by Graeme Tuckett of Stuff, who
wrote:
"[The Goldfinch] is a facsimile of a good
film.
Or perhaps a parody of one."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.